السلام علي
وبكاته شاء
الله فجر صلاه
اقامه
الله
for
[Silence]
‏ute
شاء
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان اله الا
الله اشهد ان محم رسول الله حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح قت الصلاه قت الصلاه الله
اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
[Silence]
استقيموا واستووا تراسم
واعتدلوا الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل من
يرزقكم من السماوات والارض قل الله وانا
اياكم لعلى هدى او في ضلال
مبين قل لا تسالون عما اجرمنا ولا نسال
عما
تعملون قل يجمع بيننا ربنا ثم يفتح بيننا
بالحق وهو الفتاح
العليم قل اروني الذين الحقت به شركاء
كلا بل هو الله العزيز
الحكيم وما ارسلناك الا
كافه للناس بشيرا ونذيرا ولكن اكثر الناس
لا
يعلمون ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادقين قل لكم ميعاد يوم لا تستا اخرون
عنه ساعه ولا تستقدم
وقال الذين كفروا لن نؤمن بهذا القران ولا
بالذي بين
يديه ولو ترى اذ الظالمون موقوفون عند
ربهم يرجع بعضهم الى بعض
القول يقول الذين عفوا للذين استكبروا
لولا انتم لكنا
مؤمنين قال الذين استكبروا للذين استضعفوا
انحن صددناكم عن الهدى بعد اذ
جاءكم بل كنتم
مجرمين وقال الذين استضعفوا للذين
استكبروا بل مكر الليل والنهار اذ تامرون
ان نكفر بالله ونجعل له
اندادا واسروا الندامه لما راوا
العذاب وجعلنا الاغلال في اعناق الذين
كفروا هل يجزون الا ما كانوا
يعملون وما ارسلنا في قريه من نذير الا
قال اتفو انا بما ارسلتم به
كافرون وقالوا نحن اكثر اموالا واولادا
وما نحن بمعذبين
قل ان ربي يبسط الرزق لمن
يشاء
ويقدر
ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون وما اموالكم ولا
اولادكم بالتي تقربكم عندنا زلفا الا من
امن الا من امن وعمل صالحا
فاولئك لهم
جزاء الضعف بما عملوا وهم في الغرفات
امنون والذين يسعون في اياتنا معاجزين
اولئك في العذاب
محضرون قل ان ربي يبسط الرزق لمن
يشاء من عباده ويقدر له وما
انفقتم من شيء فهو يخلفه وهو خير
الرازقين ويوم يحشرهم جميعا ثم يقول
للملائكه اهؤلاء
اياكم كانوا
يعبدون قالوا سبحانك انت ولينا من دونهم
بل كانوا يعبدون الجن اكثرهم بهم مؤمن
مؤمنون قالوا سبحانك انت ولينا من دونهم
فاليوم لا يملك بعضكم لبعض نفعا ولا ضرا
ونقول للذين ظلموا ذوقوا عذاب النار الذي
كنتم به
تكذبون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط الم
مستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا
بينات قالوا ما هذا الا
رجل قالوا ما هذا ال الا رجل مثلكم يريد
ان يصدكم عما كان يعبد
اباؤكم قالوا ما هذا الا رجل يريد ان
يصدكم عما كان يعبد
اباؤكم وقالوا ما هذا الا افك
مفترى وقال الذين كفروا للحق لما
جاءهم ان هذا الا سحر مبين وما
اتيناهم من كتب
يدرسونها وما ارسلنا اليهم قبلك من نذير
وكذب الذين من قبلهم وما بلغوا معشار ما
اتيناهم فكذبوا رسلي فكيف كان
نكير قل انما اعظكم بواحده ان تقوموا لله
مثنى وفدا ثم
تتفكروا ما
بصاحبكم من جنه ان هو الا نذير لكم بين
يدي عذاب
شديد قل ما سالتكم من اجر فهو لكم
ان اجري الا على الله وهو على كل شيء
شهيد قل ان ربي يقذف بالحق علام
الغيوب قل
جاء الحق وما يبدئ الباطل وما
يعيد قل ان ضللت فانما اضل على نفسي وان
اهتديت فبما يوحي الي ربي انه سميع
قريب ولو ترى اذ فزعوا فلا فوت واخذوا من
مكان قريب وقالوا امنا به وانا لهم
التناوش من مكان بعيد وقد كفروا به من قبل
ويقذفون بالغيب من مكان بعيد
وحيل بينهم وبين ما يشتهون كما فعل
باشياعهم
من قبل
انهم كانوا في
شك
مريب الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
ده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
ال
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
‏ma
[Silence]
س
صلاه القيام
استقيم
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الحمد لله فاطر الس السماوات والارض
جاعل
الملائكه رسلا اولي اجنحه مثنى وثلاث
ورباع يزيد في الخلق ما
يشاء ان الله على كل شيء
قدير ما يفتح الله للناس من رحمه فلا ممسك
لها وما يمسك فلا ارسل له من بعده وهو
العزيز
الحكيم يا ايها الناس اذكروا نعمه الله
عليكم هل من خالق غير الله يرزقكم من
السماء
والارض لا اله الا هو فانا
تؤفكون وان يكذبوك فقد كذبت رسل من قبل
والى الله ترجع
الامور يا ايها الناس ان وعد الله حق فلا
تغرنكم الحياه الدنيا ولا
يغرنكم بالله
الغرور ان الشيطان لكم عدو فاتخذوه
عدوا انما يدعو حزبه ليكون من اصحاب
السعير الذين كفروا لهم عذاب
شديد والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لهم
مغفره واجر
كبير افمن زين له
سوء عمله فراه حسنا فان الله يضل من
يشاء
ويهدي من
يشاء فلا تذهب نفسك عليهم
حسرات ان الله عليم بما
يصنعون والله الذي ارسل الرياح فتثير
سحابا فسقناه الى بلد ميت فاحيينا به
الارض بعد
موتها ذلك
النشور من كان يريد العزه فلله العزه
جميعا اليه يصعد الكلم الطيب والعمل
الصالح يرفعه والذين يمكرون السيئات لهم
عذاب
شديد ومكر
اولئك هو
يبور والله خلقكم من تراب ثم من نطفه ثم
جعلكم
ازواجا وما تحمل من انثى ولا تضع الا
بعلمه وما يعمر من معمر ولا ينقص من عمره
الا في
كتاب ان ذلك على الله
يسير وما يستوي البحران هذا عذب فرات
سائغ شرابه وهذا ملح
اجاج ومن كل تاكلون لحما طريا
وتستخرجون حليه
تلبسونها وترى الفلك فيه مواخر لتبتغوا من
فضله ولعلكم تشكرون
يولج الليل في النهار ويولج النهار في
الليل وسخر الشمس والقمر كل يجري
لاجل
مسى ذلكم الله ربكم له الملك والذين تدعون
من دونه ما يملكون من
قطمير ان تدعوهم لا اسمعوا
دعاءكم ولو سمعوا ما استجابوا لكم ويوم
القيامه يكفرون بشرككم ولا ينبئك مثل
خبير يا ايها الناس انتم
الفقراء الى الله والله هو الغني
الحميد ان يشاء يذهبكم ويات بخلق جديد وما
ذلك على الله
بعزيز ولا تزر وازره وزر اخرى وان تدع
مثقله الى حملها لا يحمل منه شيء ولو كان
ذا قربى انما تنذر الذين يخشون ربهم
بالغيب واقاموا
الصلاه ومن تزكى
فانما يتزكى لنفسه والى الله
المصير وما يستوي الاعمى
والبصير ولا الظلمات ولا النور ولا الظل
ولا
الحرور وما يستوي
الاحياء ولا
الاموات ان الله يسمع من
يشاء
وما انت بمسمع من في
القبور ان انت الا نذير انا ارسلناك بالحق
بشيرا
ونذيرا وان من امه الا خلى فيها نذير وان
يكذبوك فقد كذب الذين من قبلهم
جاءتهم رسلهم بالبينات وبالزبر
وبالكتاب
المنير ثم اخذت الذين كفروا فكيف كان
نكير الم تر ان الله انزل من
السماء
ماء فاخرجنا به ثمرات مختلفا
الوانها ومن الجبال جدد بيض وح امر مختلف
الوانها
وغرابيب
سود ومن الناس
والدواب والانعام مختلف الوانه
كذلك انما يخشى الله من عباده
العلماء
ان الله عزيز
غفور الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان الذين يتلون كتاب الله واقاموا
الصلاه وانفقوا مما رزقناهم سرا وعلى نيه
يرجون تجاره لن
تبور ليوفيهم اجورهم
ويزيدهم من فضله انه غفور
شكور والذي اوحينا اليك من الكتاب هو الحق
مصد
لما بين يديه ان الله بعباده لخبير
بصير ثم اورثنا الكتاب الذين اصطفينا من
عبادنا فمنهم ظالم لنفسه ومنهم مقتصد
ومنهم سابق بالخيرات باذن
الله ذلك هو الفضل
الكبير جنات عدن يدخلونها يحلون فيها من
اساور من ذهب
ولؤلؤا ولباسهم فيها
حرير وقالوا الحمد لله الذي اذهب عنا
الحزن ان ربنا لغفور
شكور الذي احلنا دار المقامه من فضله لا
يمس يسنا فيها نصب ولا يمسنا فيها
لغوب والذين كفروا لهم نار جهنم لا يقضى
عليهم فيموتوا ولا يخفف عنهم من
عذابها كذلك نجزي كل كفور وهم يصطرخون
فيها ربنا اخرجنا نعمل صالحا غير الذي كنا
نعمل اولم
نعمركم ما يتذكر فيه من تذكر
وجاءكم
النذير فذوقوا فما للظالمين من
نصير ان الله عالم غيب السماوات والارض
انه عليم بذات الصدور
هو الذي جعلكم
خلائف الارض فم فمن كفر فعليه كفره ولا
يزيد الكافرين كفرهم عند ربهم الا
مقتا ولا يزيد الكافرين كفرهم الا
خسارا قل ارايتم
شركاءكم الذين تدع
من دون الله اروني ماذا خلقوا من الارض ام
لهم شرك في
السماوات ام اتيناهم كتابا فهم على بينه
منه بل ان يعد الظالمون بعضهم بعضا الا
غرورا ان الله يمسك السماوات والارض ان
تزولا
ولئن زالتا ان امسكهما من احد ولئن زالتا
ان امسكهما من احد من بعده
انه كان حليما
غفورا واقسموا بالله جهد ايمانهم لئن
جاءهم نذير
ليكونن اهدى من احدى الامم
فلما
جاءهم نذير ما زادهم الا
نفورا
استكبارا في الارض ومكر السيء ولا يحيق
المكر السيء الا باهله فهل ينظرون الا سنه
الاولين فلن تجد لسنه الله
تبديلا ولن
تجد
لسنه الله
تحويلا اولم يسيروا في الارض
فينظروا كيف كان عاقبه الذين من قبلهم
وكانوا اشد منهم قوه وما كان الله ليعجزه
من شيء في السماوات ولا في الارض انه كان
عليما
قديرا ولو يؤاخذ الله الناس بما كسبوا ما
ترك على ظهرها من
دابه
ولكن
يؤخرهم ولكن يؤخرهم الى اجل
مسمى فاذا
جاء اجلهم فان الله كان
بعباده بصير
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه رحمه
[Silence]
الله
استقيم
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغ
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ياسين والقران
الحكيم انك لمن
المرسلين على صراط
مستقيم تنزيل العزيز
الرحيم لتنذر قوما ما انذر
اباؤهم فهم
غافلون لقد حق القول على اكثرهم فهم لا
يؤمنون انا جعلنا في اعناقهم اغلالا فهي
الى الاذقان فهم
مقمحون وجعلنا من بين ايديهم سدا ومن
خلفهم سدا
فاغشيناهم فهم لا
يبصرون
وسواء عليهم اانذرتهم ام لم تنذرهم لا
يؤمنون انما تنذر من اتبع الذكر وخشي
الرحمن بالغيب فبشره بمغفره
واجر
كريم انا نحن نحيي الموتى ونكتب ما قدموا
واثاره
وكل شيء احصيناه في امام مبين واضرب لهم
مثلا اصحاب القريه اذ
جاءها
المرسلون اذ ارسلنا اليهم اثنين
فكذبوهما فعززنا بثالث فقالوا انا
اليكم
مرسلون قالوا ما انتم الا بشر مثلنا وما
انزل الرحمن من شيء ان انتم الا
تكذبون قالوا ربنا يعلم انا اليكم
لمرسلون وما علينا الا البلاغ المبين
قالوا انا تطيرنا بكم لئن لم تنتهوا
لنرجمنكم
وليمسنكم
منا عذاب
اليم قالوا
طائركم معكم
ائن
ذكرتم بل انتم قوم
مسرفون
وجاء من اقصى المدينه رجل يسعى قال يا قوم
اتبعوا
المرسلين اتبعوا من لا يسالكم اجرا وهم
مهتدون وما لي لا اعبد الذي فطرني واليه
ترجعون ااتخذ من دونه
الهه ان يردني الرحمن بضر لا تغن عني
شفاعتهم شيئا ولا
ينقذون اني اذا لفي
ضلال
اني امنت بربكم
فاسمعون قيل ادخل
الجنه قال يا ليت قومي
يعلمون قال يا ليت قومي يعلمون بما غفر لي
ربي وجعلني من
المكرمين الله
اك
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وما انزلنا على قومه من بعده من جند
من
السماء وما كن نا
منزلين ان كانت الا
صيحه واحده فاذا هم
خامدون يا حسره على العباد ما ياتيهم من
رسول الا كانوا به
يستهزئون الم يروا كم اهلكنا من قبلهم من
القرون انهم اليهم لا
يرجعون
كل لما جميع لدينا
محضرون وايه لهم الاارض الميته احييناها
واخرجنا منها حبا فمنه
ياكلون وجعلنا فيها جنات من نخيل
واعناب وفجرنا فيها من
العيون لياكلوا من ثمره وما عملته
ايديهم افلا
يشكرون سبحان الذي خلق الازواج كلها مما
تنبت الارض ومن انفسهم ومما لا
يعلمون وايه لهم الليل نسلخ منه النهار
فاذا هم
مظلمون والشمس تجري لمستقر لها ذلك تقدير
العزيز العليم والقمر قدرناه منازل حتى
عاد كالعرجون
القديم لاشمس ينبغي لها ان تدرك القمر ولا
الليل سابق
النهار
وكل في
فلك
يسبحون وايه لهم انا حملنا ذريتهم في
الفلك
المشحون وخلقنا لهم من مثله ما
يركبون وان نشا نغرقهم فلا صريخ لهم ولا
هم
ينقذون الا رحمه منا ومتاعا الى
حين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
استغفر
عليكم السلام ا
[Silence]
حضرتك
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران
رمضان
قران شهر رمضان الذي انزل فيه القران هدى
للناس وبينات من الهدى
والفرقان رمضان
بينات من
الهر لي
القدر الله سبحانه وتالى
قران انا انزلناه في ليله القدر وما ادراك
ما ليله القدر ليله القدر خير من ال شهر
تنزل
الملائكه والروح فيها باذن ربهم من كل امر
سلام هي حتى مطلع الفجر الله سبحانه
وتعالى
[Silence]
1 جبريل عليه
السلام تنزل الملائكه والروح فيها باذن
ربهم من كل
امر
الله سبحانه
وتعالى سلام هي مطل
الفج
of اي الله سبحانه
وتالى قران محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله سبحانه
وتالى
قرانوح
المحفوظي
القدر
الرسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسل
قران رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلمي
القدر ليله
القدر الله سبحانه وتعالى فيها يفرق كل
امر
ليله
القدر الله سبحانه
وتعال
ر
[Silence]
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسل
حث مسلم
ععمر
الله الله سبحانه وتعالى كتب مقادير
الخلائق قبل خلق السماوات والارض ب ال سنه
الله سبحانه
[Silence]
وتعالى
was حديث ابعيد الخ رضي الله عنه رسول
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
نطفه
شقي life
all when are in the of
our
القدر
المحفو الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏die
القدران تعالى فيها يفرق كل امر
حكيم ليله القدر ليله القدر الله سبحانه
وتعالى س خير من الف
شهر الله سبحانه وتعالى الله سبحانه
وتعال
يعني the
age of years old man who
in الله سبحانه وتالى
قر الله سبحانه
وتالى as
done not only 83
years رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ليله
القدر رمضان انستد اعتكاف كان يجاور صلى
الله عليه وسلم في العشر الاواخر من
رمضان عائشه رضي الله
عنها نريد رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم كان اذا دخل
العشر احيا
الليل وايقظ اهله
صلاه وشد المئزر
صلى الله عليه
وسلم he would celebrate the by praying
and
do and he
would الله سبحانه
وتله القدر
الله سبحانه
وتالى geter to him
doing just like
سه the day of frid
could
سهول
علس ل
القدر رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ليله
القدر سو فمسها في العشر الاواخر من
رمضان
رمضان عبد اللهن عمر رضي
عنه
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
القدر
2ض رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ارى ان
ؤكم قد
تواط
طبعا امام ابن حجر العسقلاني رحمه الله 46
opinions about when الدر from
thear some saids ofan and is the most
authentic the
strong
that 21 23d 25th 27 29th and
ابي ابن كعب رضي الله
عنه
pointy to be dent in of and do not do
not
be
all
القدر
طبعا
[Silence]
‏and
not
all
have الله سبحانه
وتالى دعا رسول الله عائشه رضي الله عنها
اللهم انك عفو تحب والعفو فاعفو عني
اللهف مي وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين جزاكم الله
[Silence]
خي
استوا
استف شا
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
واذا قيل لهم اتقوا ما بين ايديكم وما
خلفكم لعلكم
ترحمون وما
تاتيهم من ايه من ايات ربهم الا كانوا
عنها
معرضين واذا قيل لهم انفقوا مما رزقكم
الله قال الذين
كفروا قال الذين كفروا للذين امنوا انطعم
من لو
يشاء الله اطعمه ان انتم الا في ضلال مبين
ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادقين ما ينظرون الا صيحه
واحده
تاخذهم تاخذهم وهم
خصمون فلا
يستطيعون فلا يستطيعون
توصيه ولا الى اهلهم
يرجعون ونفخ في الصور فاذا هم من الاجداث
الى ربهم
ينسلون قالوا يا ويلنا من بعثنا من
مرقدنا هذا ما وعد الرحمن وصدق
المرسلون ان كانت الا صيحه
واحده فاذا هم فاذا هم جميع لدينا
محضرون فاليوم لا تظلم نفس شيئا ولا تجزون
الا ما
كنتم
تعملون ان اصحاب الجنه اليوم في
شغل
فاكهون هم وازواجهم في ظلال على
الارائك
متكئون لهم فيها
فاكهه ولهم ما
يدعون سلام
قولا من رب
الرحيم وامتازوا اليوم ايها
المجرمون المم اعهد اليكم يا بني ادم الا
تعبدوا
الشيطان
انه لكم عدو مبين وان
اعبدوني هذا
صراط
مستقيم ولقد اضل
منكم جبلا كثيرا افلم تكونوا
تعقلون هذه جهنم التي كنم
توعدون اصلوها اليوم بما كنتم
تكفرون اليوم نختم على افواههم وتكلمنا
ايديهم وتشهد ارجلهم بما كانوا
يكسبون ولو
نشاء لطمسنا
على اعينهم فاستبقوا راط فانا
يبصرون ولو
نشاء لمسخناهم على مكانتهم فما
استطاعوا فما استطاعوا مضيا ولا
يرجعون ومن
نعمره ننكسه في الخلق افلا
يعقلون وما علمناه الشعر وما ينبغي له ان
هو الا ذكر
وقران
مبين لينذر من كان حيا ويحق القول على
الكافرين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين اولم يروا انا خلقنا لهم مما عملت مما
عملت
ايدينا انعاما فهم لها
مالكون وذللناها لهم فمنها ركوبهم ومنها
ياكلون ولهم فيها داع ومشارب افلا
يشكرون واتخذوا من دون الله الهه لعلهم
ينصرون لا
يستطيعون لا يستطيعون نصرهم وهم لهم
جند
محضرون فلا يحزنك قولهم انا نعلم ما يسرون
وما
يعلنون اولم يرى الانسان انا خلقناه من
نطفه فاذا هو خصيم
مبين وضرب لنا مثلا ونسي خلقه قال من يحيي
العظام وهي
رميم قل يحييها الذي
انشاها اول مره وهو بكل خلق
عليم الذي جعل لكم من الشجر الاخضر نارا
فاذا انتم منه
توقدون اوليس الذي خلق السماوات والارض
بقادر بقادر على ان يخلق مثلهم بلى وهو
الخلاق
العليم
انما امره اذا اراد شيئا ان يقون له كن
فيكون فسبحان الذي بيده ملكوت كل شيء
واليه
ترجعون الله
والصافات صفا فالزاجرات
زجرا فالتاليات ذكرا ان الهكم لواحد رب
السماوات والارض وما بين ما ورب المشارق
انا زينا
السماء الدنيا بزينه
الكواكب وحفظا من كل شيطان مارد لا يسمعون
الى الملا الاعلى ويقذفون من كل جانب
دحورا ولهم عذاب واصب الا من خطف الخطفه
فاتبعه شه
ثاقب
فاستفتهم اهم اشد خلقا ام من خلقنا انا
خلقناهم من طين لازب بل عجبه
ويسخرون واذا ذكروا لا
يذكرون واذا راوا ايه يستسخرون
وقالوا ان هذا الا سحر مبين ا اذا متنا
وكنا ترابا وعظاما اانا
لمبعوثون
اباؤنا
الاولون قل نعم وانتم داخرون فانما هي
زجره واحده فاذا هم
ينظرون وقالوا
يا
فاستفتهم قالوا
يا قالوا وقالوا يا ويلنا هذا يوم الدين
هذا يوم الفصل الذي كنتم به
تكذبون احشروا الذين ظلموا وازواجهم وما
كانوا
يعبدون من دون
الله فاهدوهم الى صراط
الجحيم
وقفوهم
انهم
مسؤولون ما لكم لا
تناصرون بل هم اليوم
مستسلمون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
احشروا الذين ظلموا وازواجهم وما كانوا
يعبدون من
دون وحشر الذين ظلموا وازواجهم وما كانوا
يعبدون من دون الله فاهدوهم الى صراط
الجحيم
وقفوهم انهم
مسؤولون ما لكم لا
تناصرون ما لكم لا
تناصرون بل هم اليوم
مستسلمون واقبل بعضهم على بعض
يتساءلون قالوا انكم كنتم تاتوننا عن
اليمين قالوا بل لم تكونوا مؤمنين وما كان
لنا عليكم من سلطان بل كنتم قوما
طاغين فحق علينا قول ربنا انا
ذائق فاغويناكم
انا كنا غاوين
فانهم
يومئذ في العذاب
مشتركون انا كذلك نفعل
بالمجرمين
انهم كانوا اذا قيل لهم لا اله الا الله
يستكبرون ويقولون اانا لتاركوا الهتنا
للشاعر ويقولون اانا لتاركوا الهتنا
لشاعر مجنون بل جاء بالحق وصدق المرسلين
انكم لذا ئق العذاب الاليم وما تجزون الا
ما كنتم
تعملون الا عباد الله
المخلصين
اولئك لهم رزق معلوم فواكه وهم مكرمون في
جنات
النعيم على سرر
متقابلين يطاف عليهم بكاس من معين
بيضاء لذه
للشاربين لا فيها غول ولا هم عنها
ينزفون وعندهم قاسرات
الرفعين
كانهن بيت
مكنون فاقبل بعض فاقبلت
امرا يطاف عليهم كاس من معين
بيضاء لذه
للشاربين لا فيها غول ولا هم عنها
ينزفون وعندهم قاصرات الطرف عين كانهن بيض
مكنون فاقبل بعضهم على بعض
يتساءلون قال
قائل منهم اني كان لي
قين يقول اانك لمن
المصدقين ائذا متنا وكنا ترابا وعظاما
اانا
لمدينون قال هل
انتم مطلعون فاطلع فراه في
سواء الجحيم قالت الله ان كت لتردين ولولا
نعمه ربي لكن من المحضرين افما نحن
بميتين الا موتتنا الاولى وما نحن بمعذبين
ان هذا لهو الفوز العظيم لمثل هذا لمثل
هذا فليعمل
العاملون اذلك خير ال نزلا ام شجره
الزقوم انا جعلناها في سنه
للظالمين انها شجره تخرج في اصل
الجحيم طلعها كانه رؤوس
الشياطين فانهم لاكلون منها فمالئون منها
البطون ثم انهم ل الى الج طلعها كانه رؤوس
الشياطين
فانهم لاكلون منها فمالئون منها البطون ثم
ان لهم عليها
لشوبا من
حميم ثم ان مرجعهم ى الجحيم انهم الفوا
اباءهم
طين فهم على اثارهم
يهرعون ولق ضل قبلهم اكثر
الاولين ولقد ارسلنا فيهم
منذرين
فانظر كيف كان عاقبه
المنذرين الا عباد الله
المخلصين ولقد نادانا نوح فلنعم المجيبون
ونجيناه واهله من الكرب العظيم وجعلنا
ذريته هم
الباقين وتركنا عليه في
الاخرين سلام على نوح في
العالمين انا كذلك نجزي المحسنين انه من
عبادنا
المؤمنين
ثم اغرقنا
الاخرين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين وان من شيعته
لابراهيم اذ
جاء ربه بقلب سليم اذ قال لابيه وقومه
ماذا تعبد
افك الهه دون الله تريدون فما ظنكم برب
العالمين ف فنذر نذره في
النجوم فقال اني سقيم فتولوا عنه مدبرين
فراغ الى الهتهم فقال الا تاكلون ما لكم
لا
تنطقون فراغ عليه
ضربا
باليمين فاقبلوا اليه يزفون قال اتعبدون
ما تنحتون والله خلقكم وما تعملون قالوا
ابنوا له بنيانا فالقوه في الجحيم فارادوا
به كيدا فجعلناهم الاسفلين وقال اني ذاهب
الى ربي
سيهدين رب هب لي من
الصالحين فبشرناه بغلام
حليم فلما بلغ معه السعي قال يا بني اني
ارى في المنام اني اذبحك فانظر ماذا ترى
قال يا ابت افعل ما تؤمر
ستجدني ان
شاء الله من الصابرين
فلما اسلم وت لله للجبين وناديناه ان
يا
ابراهيم قد صدقت الرؤيا انا كذلك نجزي
المحسنين ان هذا لهو
البلاء
المبين وفديناه بذبح عظيم وتركنا عليه في
الا اخرين سلام على
ابراهيم كذلك نجزي المحسنين انه من عبادنا
المؤمنين وبشرناه باسحاق نبيا من
الصالحين وباركنا عليه
وعلى
اسحاق ومن ذريتهما محسن وظالم لنفسه
مبين ود
منننا على موسى
وهارون
ونجيناهما وقومهما من الكرب العظيم
ونصرناهم فكانوا هم
الغالبين واتيناه الكتاب المستبين
وهديناهما الصراط
المستقيم وتركنا عليهما في
الاخرين سلام على موسى
وهارون انا كذلك نجزي
المحسنين انهما من عبادنا المؤمنين وان
الياس لمن المرسلين اذ قال لقومه الا
تتقون اتدعون بعلا وتذرون احسن
الخالقين الله ربكم ورب
ابائكم
الاولين فكذبوه
فانهم لمحضرون
الا عباد الله المخلصين وتركنا عليه في
الاخرين سلام على
الياسين انا كذلك نجزي المحسنين انه من
عبادنا
المؤمنين وان لوط لمن المرسلين اذ نجيناه
واهله
اجمعين الا عجوزا في
الغابرين ثم دمرنا
الاخرين وانكم لتمرون عليهم مصبحين
وبالليل افلا
تعقلون وان يونس لمن
المرسلين اذ ابق الى الفلك المشحون فساهم
فكان من المدحضين
فالتقمه الحوت وهو مليم فلولا انه كان من
المسبحين للبث في بطنه الى يوم
يبعثون فنبذناه بالعراء وهو سقيم
وانبتنا على
شجره من
يقين وارسلناه الى 100 الف او
يزيدون
وارسلنا فنبذناه بالعراء وهو سقيم
وانبتنا عل ش وانبتنا عليه شجره من
يقت وارسلناه الى مئه الف او
يزيدون فامنوا فمتعناهم الى
حين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
استقيموا اعتدلوا
استووا
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
اانتم اشد خلقا ام
السماء
بناها رفع سمكها
فسواها واغطش ليلها واخرج
ضحاها والارض بعد ذلك
دحاها اخرج منها
ماء ومرعاها
والجبال ارساها متاعا لكم ولانعامكم
فاذا
جاءت
الضامه
الكبرى يوم يتذكر
الانسان ما
سعى وبرزت الجحيم
لمن
يرى
فاما
من طغى واثر الحياه
الدنيا
فان الجحيم هي
الماوى
واما من خاف مقام ربه ونهى النفس عن
الهوى فان ان
الجنه هي
الماوى الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والضحى والليل اذا
سجى ما ودعك ربك وما قلى ولا الاخره خير
لك من
الاولى ولسوف يعطيك ربك
فترضى الم يج جدك
يتيما
فاوى ووجدك
ضالا
فهدى ووجدك
عائلا
فاغنى
فاما اليتيم فلا
تقهر
واما
السائ فلا
تنهر
واما بنعمه ربك
فحدث الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا
كثيرا طيبا مباركا فيه اللهم تم نورك
فهديت فلك الحمد عظم حلمك فعفوت فلك الحمد
بسطت يدك فاعطيت فلك الح الحمد فلك الحمد
يا ربنا على كل حال لك الحمد مل السماء
والارض ومل ما بينهما وملء ما شئت من شيء
بعد اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه
والتابعين اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما
تحول به بيننا وبين معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما
تبلغنا به جنتك ومن اليقين ما تهون به
علينا ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب
الدنيا ومتعنا
اللهم
باسماعنا
وابصارنا وقواتنا ابدا ما
لقيتنا واجعله الوارث
منا واجعله الوارث منا واجعل ثارنا على من
ظلمنا ولا تجعل مصيبتنا في
ديننا ولا تجعل الدنيا اكبر
همنا ولا مبلغ علمنا ولا الى النار
مصيرنا ولا ولا تسلط علينا بذنوبك من لا
يخافك فينا ولا
يرحمنا اللهم انا عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو
امائك نواصينا بيدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل
فينا
قضاؤك نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به نفسك
انزلته في كتابك او علمته احدا من خلقك او
استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك ان تجعل
القران العظيم ربيع
قلوبنا ونور
صدورنا وجلاء احزاننا وذهاب همومنا
وغمومنا وسابقنا الى جناتك جنات النعيم
اللهم علمنا منهما جهلناه وذكرنا منه ما
نسيناه وارزقنا تلاوته اناء
الليل واطراف النهار على الوجه الذي يرضيك
عنا اللهم تقبل منا
صلاتنا
وقيامنا
ودعائنا وصالح
اعمالنا اللهم بلغنا ليله القدر واجعلنا
فيها من
المقبولين واجعلنا فيها من المعتوقين
اللهم اعتق رقابنا ورقاب
ابائنا وامهاتنا وازواجنا
وذرياتنا واخواننا ومن احبنا فيك واحببناه
فيك اللهم اعتق رقابنا جميعا من
النار اللهم كل للمستضعفين من المسلمين في
كل مكان في غزه وفلسطين وفي السودان اللهم
كن لهم معينا
ونصيرا اللهم برحمتك لا ياتي عليهم رمضان
القادم الا بعزه وتمكين ونصر وامن
وامان برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم تقبل
منا انك انت سميع العليم وتب علينا انك
انت التواب الرحيم واخر دعوانا ان الحمد
لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
‏m
ه